congresswoman Maria Salazar of Florida
wonderful to have you what can you tell
us about that meeting
well I can tell you and thank you for
having me I can tell you that it went
well but in reality that secretary
Mallorca needs to do more and more means
to fix the problem when he is saying
that the the number of Cubans arriving
in Miami or in Key West has dwindled
it's true but it's because they just put
a little Band-Aid of giving 30
000 visas a month
I'm not sure if that's constitutional
I'm not sure if that's going to stand in
courts that's why we need and I'm happy
to say it again we need to fix the
problem for good that is to secure the
Border but secure it tight uh fix the
legal immigration so we can give the
hands to the business owners that need
employees and then give dignity to those
people who are here who've been here for
for decades illegally and that's the
plan that's why I say that's the plan
I've presented a law called the dignity
act which I think will be able to fix
the problem it's just that the political
Elite these people that are here in
Washington we the politicians we need to
once and for all fix the problem and
that's a problem that I do not see the
political willingness to do that in
Congress or in the administration okay
so Congressman Jimenez has asked
mayorkas to allow these four individual
border officials to testify we can put
them up here on the screen what do you
think
are the chances of them testifying and
what do you think you would learn if you
heard from them
of course and Carlos Jimenez who serves
District number 26 I'm in District
number 27. we were together in that
meeting and I think it's a fantastic
idea let's hear from the people who are
there in the trenches and what are they
going to tell you we are tired we cannot
sustain the situation we need help we
need resources so we need to bring the
technology that is out there listen I
want the American people to know that
this is a very fixable problem and it's
very simple just put the money that we
need in order to buy the technology I'm
talking about levies and drones and all
type of Technology we don't need to be
experts then after that we need to fix
the legal immigration and allow those
people that the economy the American
economy needs and then after that then
let's take care of the people who live
here legally simple I go back it's just
political willingness and unfortunately
the Biden Administration has not shown
the leadership the desire whatever you
want to call it in order to to fix this
problem and I represent the city of
Miami Heart of the Cuban Exile Community
Cubans nicaraguans and Venezuelans who
wouldn't want to come to the United
States everyone including my parents but
you got to do it in a legal way not in
this this array that we have how
embarrassing how embarrassing for the
rest of the world that we the number one
economy military might in the world
number one country in the world look
look what how a disarray in our own home
so I feel very bad but you know that's
why I presented the dignity act okay I
have one last quick question we run out
of time a little bit we started off the
show today we were talking about the
migrant crisis as it affects New York
City and mayor Eric Adams saying that he
needs more help from the federal
government as well but in particular
there are a lot of strains on this city
can you tell us in a nutshell what is it
like in Miami what kind of pressure is
that city under
the same 10 000 new school students in
the public school system no one can
sustain that so those are the kids what
about the hospitals what about the roads
everything gets more congested but those
are not taxpayers because those people
that have been allowed to come in by the
Biden Administration are not receiving a
work permit they receive government help
so could you imagine how distorted this
is they let you in we don't know who you
are but we're going to give you food
stamps so we're not going to give you
the ability to make a living unbelief
believable so we the political class
Congress needs to step up to the plate
and say okay let's fix this mess and
that's why I introduced my dignity act
well I'm going to take a look at that
which is not amnesty let me just tell
you about amnesty don't let them fool
you okay it's not amnesty amnest is what
they have now because now they don't pay
for roads for school or for uh hospitals
so yes advise me next time and I will
explain to you my dignity yeah
congresswoman thank you for being on our
show we'll stay in touch with you sure
thanks I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis